i think
for lots of people the single hardest
thing
that we will ever do
is admit that not only were we wrong
but we've been wrong for a long time
[Music]
hey there folks it has been a while
since i've talked about toxic fandom in
a broad sense i've done a couple of
videos previously i'll link the more
recent one up there because i'll kind of
refer to that at least a little bit in
the lead up to this
and
i've had this on my mind for a little
bit and i kind of want to dive into it
because the most recent what i did
was talking about how a lot of what
seems to drive uh toxic fandom behavior
and interactions
stems from this idea that based off your
opinion on a piece of media people will
make all sorts of assumptions
about your beliefs
and so an opinion becomes an agenda
so suddenly liking something or
disliking something else
puts you
into certain
boxes
of a particularly charged and often
politicized spectrum when all you did
was say oh i kind of like this or i kind
of don't like that
i want to dig a layer deeper underneath
that and sort of examine what i think
personally is one of the reasons why
the assumption gets built
that a certain opinion corresponds
with a belief and or an agenda
now there are
other reasons why this happens but i do
think that one of the big reasons
and one of the big
issues underscoring a lot
of toxic fan behavior particularly
towards other fans
is
ego defense
i don't know how much
that gets talked about in general i mean
people talk about
things like white fragility
um fragile masculinity and this is i
guess in the same neighborhood but the
thing is regardless of whether you are
male or white or whatever
the vast majority of us
have
base assumptions
about
ourselves that we assume in order to
operate and function and move forward
and core to those assumptions is usually
a fundamental belief that
what we think
is most likely correct
now this kind of gets solidified more
and more and more as you grow older
because when you're a bit younger and
when you're still
learning a lot of things for the first
time
hopefully
ideally you're a bit more open to the
possibility of oh okay so this thing
that i'd assumed well that's not right
let's
let's adapt the new information come up
with something new
i think a lot of us hit a point and it's
not a hard line i think it's a gradation
in our lives where
we kind of want to stop
changing
and we kind of want to just
be able to assume that what we know and
believe is already correct
it's sort of the opposite of
actual rational thought process because
a rational thought process is
i will take in the information available
and then based off that information i
will either come to a firm or adjust my
conclusion
whereas everything i'm going to talk
about is kind of coming from a base
assumption of i assume i'm already right
but there's a reason for that assumption
which is we tie a lot of ourselves
up in the things that we both believe
and that we do
so how does this manifest this idea of
defending one's ego how does that help
escalate
what might just be a dispute of opinion
into something
harsher
more toxic
well
if you
start from a position of
i like
this
geeky property
because of x
and somebody else says oh i like this
too but i like
i like why about it i don't like x so
much
now on the surface that should be able
to just be oh well we like different
things about it well that's fine
but there's questions
that go on in the background
of a lot of our heads that we may not
even realize are going unconsciously
questions like
if other people like this thing that i
like
for reasons other than why i like it
does it mean that i'm right about what's
good about this thing
what if the things that they say they
like about it are specifically things
that i don't
like does that mean that they're right
about a property and i'm wrong
well if we come back back to what i said
before about
most of us operating on a base
assumption of assuming we're already
right
then what's the natural conclusion so
that we don't have to challenge that
assumption
those are fake fans or those are people
trying to twist something i love into
something else and not what it truly is
because i like it
for the right reasons and they like it
for the wrong reasons
if you and i don't recommend doing this
but if you
venture into some of the
more hate-fueled areas of fandom of any
fandom
then you're gonna very quickly start to
find incredibly conspiratorial
narratives
where it's not just a matter of there
are fans that
are being catered to that are turning
this in that are turning this property
in a direction we don't like but it
becomes
they are intentionally
ruining this thing for us
it's not just a matter of they also like
it but for different reasons no no no no
this is part of
an agenda so there we are coming back to
this thing of opinions are also agendas
because if they legitimately engage with
this thing the way that i do
and they came to a different conclusion
about what was good about it
well that might mean that i have to
examine my ideas i don't want to do that
so instead i'm just going to go well
what they say they like they're lying
or they don't understand it
or
as it gets more twisted
they are coming in
to take this away from me
because if you adopt the idea
that these other people
are not actually fans of a thing but are
trying to ruin it
well for many fans that will justify
harsh
responses
not just of trying to expel them from
your immediate fan circle
but
seeking them out
stopping the agenda that you've ascribed
to them
and this leads to the kind of behavior
of people going and leaving
harsh or argumentative or abusive
comments on months or years old videos
and old comments i have to clean this
kind of stuff up all the time
and i block anyone who does it it
doesn't even matter what your opinion is
if you are coming into my comments and
leaving
argumentative comments on video on
comments on a video from a year or more
ago you are just a sh stirrer
you are here to start fights
and you want to start fights because
if you get the other side riled up that
will justify
more harsh action from you
the ultimate end point of this
and the reason that it gets clung to
harder and harder every step along the
way
of getting harsher
in your response in your reaction
to someone
just disagreeing with you about a thing
you like
is that in the end
you need the other people to be the
whole
and you'll construct insane
conspiratorial narratives to make them
the whole
because if they aren't
then you definitely are
when it escalates to a point of you
actively attacking
people
who don't share your opinion
you have to paint them as bad as
possible
because otherwise
you are the bad guy
and nobody wants to be the bad guy
even people who are all oh
i don't care about your feelings i don't
care what you think of me
they still want to think that they're
the good guy
and um
if you've been
thinking about what i've been saying
uh yeah this applies to more than fandom
the conspiratorial narratives of
things like
gamergate
of
turfs
i had a very bizarre
accusation
hurled at me and a comment
on a video i put up on my vera wild
channel
where i talk
more specifically and openly about my
experiences as a gender fluid person
and
it was a video in which i
got a little bit vulnerable and talked
about something that had kind of shaken
me in experience
and there was this commenter
going through and every comment where
someone said oh i can see that this was
hard for you to talk about
this person was commenting
don't believe
don't believe them
they're a liar
they're a trained actor
i am not a trained actor
i'm a failed actor i did try and make an
acting but i have i have more of a claim
to being a trained mathematician
than a trained actor in terms of the
amount of schooling i actually got on
the subject
and it's a not completely illogical leap
from the fact that you can look at my
imdb and see that i took a crack at
acting to then claim that i am a trained
actor and if i'm trained actor then you
can't believe any vulnerability i show
in a video because i could fake it
ignoring the fact that even being a
trained actor does not make you
incapable of expressing genuine
vulnerability you don't lose that
but even setting that aside
the reason someone would jump onto that
is because it fits their conspiratorial
narrative
they went into my comments section
having already decided
that i'm a liar and that anything i say
that feels like vulnerability is
attempting to get sympathy to get people
to my side of some political issue as
opposed to just sharing a personal
experience
and whatever
narrative will fit that
they'll integrate it in
and it becomes more twisted
and more conspiratorial
and it's the same mentality
that gets
people saying that any woman who has had
success in the video game industry got
it by sleeping with people
it's the same mentality as qanon who
claim to believe
that anyone of a liberal mindset is
literally a demon worshiping baby killer
because they've already taken it
their part in this
debate
to such a level that that's what the
other side would have to be
in order for them
to not be the bad guy see people look at
what
organizations and movements like q and
on claim to actually believe and go they
can't really think this and i'm not sure
they do on an intellectual level
but it's what they need to be true
and when it comes to
terfs
the
narrative that
trans women which i'm not by the way but
they don't care
the narrative that trans women
aren't just
existing in a space with them but are
predators and anyone who is a trans
advocate is actively attempting to
attack and undermine women and women's
freedom and women's spaces and to make
it more dangerous for them to live they
need that to be true
to justify the actions they are taking
to try and clamp down on the rights of
trans people
and just like how
in fandoms
you get accusations
that
there is a agenda
being pushed
people coming in to destroy
a piece of geekdom that they like and
why it isn't okay to simply enjoy the
thing you enjoy but you have to go out
and attack
anything that is in opposition to the
thing you enjoy and i've always said
that these elements of toxic fandom have
always been there because they have
but
the age we live in
accelerates things now
if you see somebody else exhibiting this
behavior
trying to pull them out is going to be
very difficult
because as i said a lot of the spawns
from a need to defend one's
self one's understanding of oneself as
the good guy
so anyone who's telling you that you
aren't
you're gonna fight against that because
it's not a
notion that you're going to want to deal
with
so i think the best thing that we can do
is try and keep an eye on ourselves
and how we are engaging
with
other fans of a work especially
fans who we disagree with
because
we should be able to say
i also like
doctor who
and i like the chimneal era
or be able to say
i also like doctor who but i do not like
the chivnalera
and not
have this side accusing this one of
pushing a political correctness agenda
and a deliberate attempt to undermine
the show and turn it into the opposite
of what it used to be and without this
side accusing this side of being
misogynist bigots who absolutely loathe
anything with a woman at the front of it
it's a show
you can disagree about a show
and if you feel the need to
paint
the other side of a disagreement
with the worst possible brush
try to pause
and ask yourself why am i doing that
why do i need them
to be that bad
what am i trying to justify
by making them worse
what behavior am i excusing in myself
by making them
look like monsters
and that is why
i will always come back to this quote
from big finish the holy terror is the
sixth doctor story
it does not matter to whom the cruelty
is directed the cruelty itself is wrong
as fans as human beings
it's very easy
to excuse
mistreating someone by simply
categorizing them as lesser
as not being worthy
of respect or dignity
but they are and if you're acting
towards them in a way that
needs them to not be worthy of dignity
ask yourself why
and if the reason you need them to be
the bad guy is actually
worth it because at the very least when
it comes to fan arguments
i would say it
it almost never is
but
try and keep track of yourself
i try and keep track of myself
can't say i'm perfect
nobody is but i do my best
and i hope you will too
thanks so much for hearing me out on
this it's been on my mind for a little
while and
yeah for various reasons certain things
keep cropping up and fan of spaces or my
comments or whatever that put it back in
my head can't imagine why
but in any case
you take care
and whatever your thoughts are on what
i've said here drop something down the
comments let's talk about it
like share subscribe i'll help me out i
have a patreon which is what actually
pays my bills
and any help there
is of great assistance but
no pressure
at the end of the day what i really want
you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council i am just running
the meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
this video wouldn't have been possible
without the support of my patrons and i
want to give special thanks to jared
boyce
mj the doctor tracy scrabbit vincent
paul bartolucci kalyn schwartz edelon
robin moore ross schultz and shayla
gourley
thanks so much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]